fish are 2002 pop coffee
employee training film with your host
Ralph Henderson hello
I'm Ralph Henderson and if you're
watching this video that means you've
just been hired to work here popular
copy me and my friends are gonna show
you the basis of what it's like to work
here you guys ready yeah great first of
all never show up on time and if a
supervisor happens to ask you where you
were your responses sounds something
like this and well why are you late I
got you when I could mom perfect
servicing the line occasionally you may
get snagged by one of these customer
people just remember your job is to
frustrate them and make them feel
unwanted if you can wrap up a story
that'll make them feel uncomfortable
for instance you understand what I'm
saying right I mean you know my
reputation I mean I don't give a
I'll go to Rikers for 3 or 4 years just
to prove my point I mean I don't play
that can help you or hell yeah suck
toes good afternoon welcome to popcopy'
can I help you oh my crazy I took a
shower you know
computer technology if a customer has a
computer disk then look at it and tell
miss the wrong format if they use Apple
tell them we're PC they use PC tell them
we're Apple and if they got both then
tell them we use Linux and if they got
that tell them the computers are down
they should be anyhow the whole system
actually went down its gonna be shut
down for a couple hours
[Music]
I gotta go take a your management
should a customer get all uppity and ask
to speak to a manager and tell them
guess what I am the manager I want to
see some owners oh yeah no see I am the
manager you are that's right my friend
I'm the only man to you unless you want
to talk to the popcopy' president and I
don't know yeah you might can help me
out with that I mean really getting
their face about it I want to see your
manager you're the manager you you've
done that's it your job is run nigga get
out you know a lot of people ask why why
treat the customer this way why because
them that's why bathroom upkeep
bathroom upkeep is important to us here
at pop cupboard
be sure to spray chocolate sauce on the
wall near the toilet to give the
appearance of errant feces this will
ensure that any customer who used our
restroom will never ever return to one
of our store we ask that you sign a
sheet to verify this gets done once an
hour 24 times a day Oh Tony you missed a
spot
well now that looks poopy I hope you
found this tape informative and should
you ever doubt yourself and consider
treating a customer with respect just
remember this you graduated from grade
school and you don't have to take
from anyone
welcome to the popcopy' family and
congratulations
[Applause]